I think like college is going to be
necessary with all with everything
coming out like VR AI try gbt I think
for a lot of people college is right
they are comfortable in a more
structured environment they know the
systems and for a lot of those people
college is right because they'll go to a
good school that will set up a good job
and that's how they'll live their lives
College was not right for me because I'm
too outside the box and I think it's
cool that Society over the next 30 Years
will not put pressure on 18 year olds to
have to go there especially if they're
collecting debt my biggest thing always
about college is for a kid that it's not
right for to be forced by their parents
and society and their teachers to go to
college and collect debt was a disaster
for a lot of you you might be fortunate
where your parents will pay for it or
your talents and sports or academics
will pay for it but if College isn't
right for you and you take on debt it
stinks and it's going to become more and
more obvious so I think it's cool that
in 10 years only 70 is going to go to
college instead of 100 20 years ago